[Music]
your mom is the actress Lea Thompson and
your dad is director Howard Deutsch so
somewhere oh yeah I'm sure they found
him a seat or something you act like
he's wandering around in the rap so okay
now did you know what your mom did is a
kid I mean she was in movies and
television did you how aware of you of
your mom's Fame I thought I knew what
she did I when I was little like I was I
guess I was scrolling through the TV and
and I came across okay you guys ever
seen Howard the Duck has anyone okay
there's a particular scene in the film
in which my mother makes love to a duck
and you started as a child I thought so
and so uh what's the next step I go to
my father I see like my mother I'm like
oh my god I know the duck's name was
Howard dad your name is Howard this is
complicated dad will love you more than
this duck will like yeah I was really
like making a case for oh you thought
that she was gonna leave your dad for a
duck duck I'm so eventually it's for
grown-ups
you know don't you don't need to watch
that we weren't supposed to see that and
so at school when people would ask me
what my mom does for a living I would
say I would say she's an actress mm-hmm
in adult films they said that
that's terrific this was last week I
know it sounds like I was in
kindergarten as was wobbly
you